good evening you're gonna set through
just a couple introductions here if you
can bring up the next slide please for
the last two talks we haven't had any AV
so we haven't done a long short but this
one just appeared in my inbox yesterday
from Stuart candy our research fellow
who actually coined this term long short
and these are short films that exemplify
long term thinking this one is the
history of the world in a hundred
seconds it was actually done by an
associate of long now that showed this
at one of the meetups I believe in
London it's by Gareth Lloyd and Tom
Martin and what they did is grabbed all
of the Wikipedia entries and actually I
think Denis Cooper the CTO of Wikipedia
is here so you can thank her for this
data well and all the people who have
entered it of course but the they mapped
it with they grabbed all that stuff that
had a geotag as well as a time tag and
so what you'll see are little points
that start to show up like the picture
of the Earth from space at night and in
the bottom right it's kind of faint but
you'll see the years going by and since
2500 years of historical events popping
up over time roll the short thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
keep that image in your mind
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation Matt Ridley is the
antidote to in this book is book called
the rational optimist to what is
portrayed in another book I'll recommend
to you called the idea of decline in
Western history in Western civilization
and for some reason Western
intellectuals keep liking to tell each
other that things are going to hell and
here's why and here's who's the blame
and things like that here's the antidote
Matt Ridley
Woody Allen once said that mankind
stands at a crossroads one road leads to
despair and total extinction the other
to utter hopelessness
let us pray we have the wisdom to make
the right choice it's that attitude that
Stuart has just said I think is all too
prevalent and that I want to try and
dissuade you from tonight now it might
seem very cheeky for a Brit from gloomy
old Europe to come over here to
wonderful San Francisco where you're
also optimistic and try and teach you
optimism and it actually to be a little
more serious for a second it might seem
cheeky in a week when 20,000 people have
died in a disaster to say that the world
can get better and that the future can
be better than the past just two things
about Japan there that I want to say
before I go on the first is that because
Japan was so wealthy many fewer people
died than would have done if Japan had
had the per capita income of Haiti as we
know from the Haitian earthquake
recently something like 300,000 people
might have died in collapsed buildings
and if Japan had had the per capita
income of Burma something similar might
have happened with the tsunami because
300,000 people died in a cyclone in in
in Burma recently so it's the very fact
that it had the infrastructure the
communications the technology that so
many people did not die and that's what
I want to try and talk about tonight how
do we raise human living standards how
do we improve the condition of people on
the planet and can we go on doing it on
my desk at home sits this object it's an
Australian hand axe from half a million
years ago it's of a design that he was
used by Homo erectus for nearly a
million years possibly more
it's a beautiful technology and it is a
technology but it didn't change
it was used all over the world and it
didn't change for a million years that's
30,000 generations of technology without
innovation it's an extraordinary
phenomenon when you think about it and
right next to it sits this object which
is exactly the same shape and size and
serves roughly the same purpose in other
words I use it to execute my needs and
it's of course five years old and it's
out of date already and it's this
concept of innovation this perpetual
change that I think is is key to
understanding human evolution now there
is a big difference between these two
objects as well one is made from a
single substance the other is made from
a confection of different substances
indeed from different ideas the idea of
plastic the idea of metal the idea of
computing the idea of the laser they've
all occurred to different people in
different places at different times and
yet they've been embodied together in
this object and that I think is the key
to understanding why human technology
can raise living standards because it
brings together ideas effectively to
meet and to mate or as I put it it
allows ideas to have sex every
technology we use when you think about
it is a combination of other
technologies other ideas the pill camera
is my favorite example it takes a
picture of your insides as it goes
through it came about after a
conversation between a
gastroenterologist and a guided missile
designer why did this happen to us and
why now why to the human species and why
in the last hundred thousand years or so
what's so special about this moment in
the long now I don't think the the
answer for explaining the human take off
of the last hundred thousand years is
culture because Jeff chimpanzees have
culture they teach each other how to
crack nuts with rocks they pass down
traditions I don't think it's
self-awareness it's clear that all sorts
of other animals have at least budding
self-awareness and I don't think it's
language because now that we've looked
at the genes of Neanderthals we've
discovered that they had the same gene
adaptations to or from language that we
have the Fox p2 mutation in particular
and we know that the split from the
Neanderthals happened at least 400,000
years ago so what is it what what was
the trigger that changed human behavior
to this perpetual innovation machine if
you look at the size of the human brain
over the last few million years and you
plot on this where things happen that we
think of as as distinctly human they
kind of all come too early to explain
our take off we were standing on two
legs at least four million years ago so
we freed our hands which we think is an
important thing we invented tools two
and a half million years ago and yet as
I said with the Australian hand axe
nothing really happened we just had
tools we didn't encounter innovation we
invented fire we don't know when
sometime between half a million and one
and a half million years ago it had an
enormous impact because he didn't able
just to pre digest our food and that
meant we could have smaller guts and
that meant we could have bigger brains
but it's not immediately clear that it
was the thing that triggered take-off
and even language as I say we don't know
when it happened but it looks like it
comes too early in the story to explain
this extraordinary take-off what I think
explains human explosion into global
dominance is the invention of exchange
the invention of the idea that you swap
one thing for another
and no other animal does this other
animals do reciprocity you scratch my
back I scratch yours but they don't swap
different things at the same time they
might occasionally do it between a mated
pair where sex is swapped for food in in
various insects and birds but the
general idea that strangers would go up
to each other and swap things I've got
more of this than I need you've got more
of that than you need let's swap them it
doesn't happen in other species as Adam
Smith famously said no man ever saw a
dog make fair and deliberate exchange of
a bone with another dog and the effect
this had on cultural evolution was
exactly the same I think as the effect
that the invention of sex had on
biological evolution
the invention of sex in a accelerated
and made cumulative for the first time
genetic mutation and evolution here's an
example in an asexual species as its
evolving along you get two different
mutations a red one and a green one one
of them has to go extinct to make way
for the other one if the other one's
better because you can only inherit the
mutation from your direct lineage
whereas in a sexual species at some
point an individual is going to inherit
a mutation from both mutations from
different parents and it's if they're
both good mutations then it can
accumulate them it can get different
mutations onto the same into the same
individuals so what sex does is it
allows the species to draw upon the
genetic inventive 'no sul species not
just its own lineage an exchange has the
same impact on human culture because of
exchange because of trade we can draw
upon the inventiveness of people in San
Francisco and Shanghai at the same time
now I want to step back a little first
and just talk about whether or not human
beings are better off now than they have
been before and to try and persuade you
that they are and then I'm going to come
back to this process of ideas having sex
to explain why well we're obviously
producing more goods and services in the
world this is world product corrected
for inflation but of course there are
more others so you'd expect that so
let's correct it for population and
throw the graph back 2,000 years instead
of 200 years and it's still pretty
spectacular with an inflection point at
the Industrial Revolution let's go even
further back let's go back a million
years where admittedly the economic data
gets a little sketchy and and we can see
that it looks like the growth rate of
world GDP per capita is increasing in
other words there's an acceleration of
GDP per capita going on and just look at
the numbers we're heading for here one
hundred thousand to two hundred thousand
dollars per head globally in today's
dollars
before the end of this century that's
the trajectory were on that our
grandchildren will have an income three
to six times as high as the average
American today globally all around the
world those are amazing numbers if they
can be sustained so it's very
interesting I think to understand
whether or not this is possible
what about recessions we know all about
them they're horrible and they're
painful and we're in one at the moment
but if you look on the long scale as I
think the long now foundation likes one
to do then they don't on the whole make
that much difference if you look here's
the Great Depression in American GDP and
here's the Great Recession and in but
what's striking about the graph is not
the dips but the the inexorable increase
in GDP per capita in between and it's
not at the expense it's not just rich
people getting rich at the expense of
poverty poverty is declining there are
many ways of measuring it this is one of
them people living on less than a
constant 1990 dollar a year as measured
by Xavier salary Martin and this is not
what most people think this is not what
the world leaders signed up to at Rio in
1992 they said we're confronted with the
worsening of poverty in any one poverty
was declining at the time and it's still
declining it's even declining in Africa
now it wasn't in the 1980s and 1990s but
it's now declining pretty rapidly Africa
Africa had five and a half percent
economic growth last year many
environmentalists still haven't got that
message and think that it's not possible
to get Africa out of poverty I think
they're wrong I actually think that we
will see Africa following Asia into
increasing prosperity in years to come
but of course money isn't the only
measure of how well-off you are what
really counts
the real metric of prosperity is time
how long does it take you to fulfill one
of your needs if you had to get up in
the morning and supply yourself with
food and clothing and shelter and
entertainment and all that it would take
you a long time to supply each of those
needs how long do you actually need to
work to fulfill one of those needs today
let's take electric light if you want to
read a book by the
of an 18 watt compact fluorescent bulb
for an hour this evening and I hope it's
mine then how long would you have had to
work if you're on the average wage and
the answer is about half a second back
in 1950 you'd have had to work for eight
seconds on the average wage to earn that
much light from an incandescent bulb
that's seven and a half seconds of
economic growth which has appeared in
the world since then seven and a half
seconds that you can now spend earning
something else or if you're my children
leaving the light on and back in 1880
you'd have had to work for fifteen
minutes to earn that much lamp light
from a kerosene lamp in 1800 the average
person would have had to work for six
hours to acquire that much light in the
form of a tallow candle the average
person in 1800 could not afford a candle
that's the real measure the reduction in
the amount of time you have to spend to
fulfill a need or a demand and how is
that possible well in the end it's due
to technology but why does technology
help it helps essentially because of
this comparative advantage the only
proposition it has once been said in the
whole of the social sciences that is
both true and surprising David Ricardo a
London stockbroker came up with this
idea basically in 1817 and he was trying
to explain why it's worth a country
trading with another country even if
it's worse than that other country at
producing everything and here's his
explanation in Stone Age terms there are
two men sitting around a fire and they
need an a spear and an axe to go out
hunting Adam is rather slow at making
both Spears and axes Oz is faster at
making both but ours is slightly better
at Spears and Adam is certainly better
at axes so all's doesn't need Adam does
he he should just make a spear in an axe
and leave Adam and go off hunting well
no because you've all want to make two
Spears and Adam were to make two axes
and then they were to trade then they
would each have saved an hour of work
because odds would have worked for two
hours instead of three and Adam would
have work
6,000 stead of seven and of course this
is only true because Oz is better at
Spears and Adam is better Dax's but if
you think about it if they're trading
then that's bound to be true because Oz
is gonna get more practice at making
Spears and adamant making axes and so
the more they exchange the more they're
going to specialize and the more they
specialize the more value there is in
exchange it's a sort of perpetual motion
machine that builds up if they work for
each other they can raise each other
standard of living so if you go back to
this image and you ask yourself who made
the objects the the axe was made by
someone for himself the mouse was made
by a team of people for me they got
together one day and they said Matt
Ridley needs a computer mouse let's make
him one how many of them were in that
team there are hundreds thousands I
think probably millions because you've
got to include the man who was growing
coffee in Brazil to feed the man on the
oil rig who was drilling for oil whose
oil would be used to make the plastic
etc etc they were all involved in this
cooperative enterprise to make me a
computer mouse they were all working for
me in the old days you got rich by
having people working for you quite
literally louis xiv it's a fair bet he
didn't make that silly outfit for
himself louie xiv had 498 people to
prepare his dinner every night but
here's a bunch of tourists going around
his palace in versailles and each of
them when you think about it has 498
people preparing his dinner tonight
they're working in bistros and cafes and
restaurants and shops all over Paris but
they're ready at an hours notice to drop
everything and produce a meal for one of
these people they're working for him in
just the sense that people were working
for nuit xiv now other animals have the
habit of working for each other too
particularly the social insects where
the workers work for the Queen and the
Queen works for the workers but there's
one big difference in social insects it
only happens within the family because
that's what a colony is it's a big
family where everybody is related to the
Queen and they have a reproductive
division of labor that is to say they
also
for each other in terms of reproduction
they delegate reproduction that's the
one thing we are not comfortable doing
it's the one thing we like to do for
ourselves even in England we don't
expect the Queen to do our reproducing
for us and of course what that means is
that we can work we've extended this
process to working for strangers whereas
in the ant colony you only work for
members of the colony and if you think
about it farming is also a division of
labour that's extended to other species
in this picture the Shepherd is working
for the sheep and the sheep are working
for the dog and the dog is working for
the man they're all working for each
other they're all raising each other
standard of living by specializing in
what they're good at so when did this
happen when did we start exchanging
things the best way of finding evidence
is to find archaeological evidence of
objects moving long distances because we
know from modern Aborigines like modern
hunter gatherers like aboriginals in
Australia it's because of trade not
because of migration and when does this
first happen in the human fossil record
and the answer is around 120,000 years
ago that's by the way ten times as old
as agriculture trade is ten times older
than agriculture the first thing you see
is obsidian hand axes in Ethiopia start
to move long distances from the site
from the volcano where they've been
quarried but about the same time you see
these shells which are clearly being
used as beads moving up to a hundred
miles inland in Algeria from the sea and
that looks like it's the beginning of
people exchanging things with each other
across boundaries and it must have been
very difficult to evolve because
remember up until that point like
chimpanzees today no two males from
neighboring bands could meet without
trying to kill each other and yet we've
tried trading with each other instead
the effect this has is that human
technology the sophistication of human
technology depends upon the size of the
population that's involved in the
exchange
in the Pacific before Western contact
fishing tackle like this was more
sophisticated on islands that had bigger
trading networks than on islands which
were more isolated but that is to say
the more contact you had with other
people the more sophisticated technology
you could produce so there's a kind of
collective brain phenomenon going on
here that what determines the amount of
technology we can produce is not how
clever we are but how much were in
contact with other people and you can
even see that what happens when you
isolate people has happened for example
in Tasmania when it became an island
10,000 years ago that point it was a
peninsula off the southeast corner of
Australia what happened after that was
not just that the Tasmanians had a
slower progress of technology than the
mainland Australians their technology
actually went into reverse they gave up
a number of technologies that they had
inherited at the start in particular
bone tools they gave up how to make them
it wasn't because they were becoming
stupider it was because their collective
brain was too small to sustain the
specialization and exchange to keep
technology evolving and as a little
check a little cross experiment Tierra
del Fuego did not suffer this why not
its similarly inhospitable island with a
similarly small population of
hunter-gatherers well the answer is
because Tierra del Fuego is separated
from South America by a very narrow
strait the Magellan Strait whereas
Tasmania is separated by the Bass Strait
and there was continuous trading contact
across the Magellan Strait throughout
this period so for a G ins were drawing
upon a collective brain the size of
South America go back to this image
again and ask yourself not just who made
the Mouse for me but who knew how to
make a mouse and the answer is nobody
there is no person on the planet who
knows how to make a computer mice that
seem that might seem a rather rude thing
to say in the Bay Area but it's true the
compressor dent of the computer mouse
company doesn't know how to make a mouse
he just knows how to run a company the
person on the assembly line does
to make mus cuz he doesn't know how to
drill an oil well you need to drill an
oil well to get the oil out to make the
plastic and so on the knowledge of how
to make most of our technologies is
distributed collectively across society
it is not held in individual brains that
by the way is why I'm not very
interested in IQ and the debate about
whether one group is cleverer than
another what counts is not how clever
people are but how well they're
communicating and that by the way is of
course why central planning doesn't work
because you're asking one person to be
cleverer than the collective knowledge
of many people I have of course just
been quoting from a famous essay by an
economist called Leonard recalled I
pencil in which he pretends to be a
pencil and tries to understand his own
origins and concludes that nobody knows
how to make him even though he got made
and I think that's the magic of human
technology of course we've now connected
our brains so that ideas can meet and
mate faster than ever before thanks to
the Internet and if you take a picture
of the Internet it looks like a brain it
is a brain we're nodes in its neural
network ourselves and we cannot but be
accelerating the rate of human
innovation as a result so perhaps that
hundred thousand to two hundred thousand
dollar estimate of GDP in the 2100 per
capita might even be an underestimate
well okay well better off but are we
healthier happier clever a kinder
cleaner more peaceful and more equal yes
we're healthier we're living about 30
percent longer than when I was born life
expectancy is increasing globally at
about five hours a day that's because
we're defeating premature mortality this
is data from Britain but you can see the
collapse of infectious disease of
respiratory disease and more recently of
strokes and heart attacks circulatory
disease and you can see that non
appearance of a cancer epidemic that
would shorten our lives as many
environmentalists thought it would in
the 1960s and 1970s
and you can even see on this is us data
that cancer is beginning to fall
we are beginning to win against cancer
we're cleverer iqs going up in all
countries nobody quite knows why it's
called the Flynn effect it's going up
about three points a decade it's
probably because we're getting to poor
kids who have who used to be sick and
and not get proper nutrition and we're
making sure they get it something like
that we're happier
most people think there's no correlation
between happiness and wealth but it's
not true there is both within countries
and between countries and within
individual life zones the happier you
are on the whole the more likely you the
wealthier you are the more happy you are
it's not a linear correlation and of
course you can be very rich and unhappy
but that's a good thing because it makes
the rest of us happy we're kinder this
is donations to charity as a proportion
of GDP in the UK I'm sure it's the same
over here on the whole it's going up
well cleaner air pollution is is on the
way down so is water pollution in nearly
all of the Western world and it's
getting worse in places like Beijing but
on the whole we know that as you get
richer it is possible to start cleaning
up your environment a car produces about
90 percent less pollution in terms of
volatile organic compounds carbon
monoxide and nitrogen oxides as it did
in the 1970s per mile traveled this
wasn't expected Life magazine said in
1970 that by 1985 air pollution would
have reduced the amount of sunlight
reaching the earth by half were more
peaceful were less likely to kill each
other than at any time in history the
2000s was the decade with the smallest
number of deaths in war since 1945 most
people find that hard to believe but
that's because we live in countries
which did have a rather bad decade for
war deaths in the last decade but
globally fewer people died in that
decade the in war than in any previous
decade since the second world war were
more equal inequalities falling it has
to be falling when you think about it
because poor countries are getting rich
faster than rich countries are getting
rich so they're catching up so Indians
and Chinese are getting rich whereas
American
not getting rich nearly as fast and
that's bound to reduce global inequality
can this go on am I just the man who
falling past the second floor of the
skyscraper says so far so good well I'd
like to point out that we've been
expecting it to come to a horrible halt
for a long time in the past we've had
all sorts of reasons to fear that that
Armageddon was just around the corner
this is a new tool from Google enabling
you to count the number of mentions of a
particular word in books over time and
the yellow line is the mention of the
word eugenics which peaks in the early
20th century and remember this was a
real scare at the time everybody thought
that the human race was deteriorating
because of the over breeding of the
feeble-minded and something must be done
very urgently about it in the great big
national Commission's and things and
people like Winston Churchill and
Theodore Roosevelt and George Bernard
Shaw were determined that this was an
urgent problem and we didn't do very
much well we did a little bit too much
about it in some countries but but you
know it turned out not to be the problem
that people expected fluoridation do you
remember that poisoning of our bodily
fluids that was going on in dr.
Strangelove the word nuclear war peaks
in the early sixties and again in the
80s the phrase population explosion
peaks in the 70s the word pesticide in
the 70s and 90s
acid rain peaks in the in the late 80s
and 90s the y2k computer bug do you
remember that and that was going to
bring civilization to a grinding halt on
the 31st of December 1999 GM foods and
of course most recently climate change
and my point is simply that with the
exception of the last one where the jury
is still out
all of them proved incapable of
preventing the inexorable improvement of
human living standards all of them were
in a sense false alarms take population
for example many people think population
is still out of control in some sense
it's not the rate of population increase
has been falling for a long time it was
2% in the 1960s it's 1% today than
absolute
number of people added to the world
population has been falling now since
the 1980s for 20 years and this isn't
because we adopted the policy
recommendation of most experts in the
1960s that we would have to go for
coercion that we would have to pass laws
about how many children people could
have well one country did that but the
rest of us didn't and we saw just as
rapid a decline in the birth rate why
because of benign factors because
essentially we got rid of child
mortality in most countries and
therefore people began to plan smaller
families because people got richer and
better educated and decided to invest in
quality of children rather than quantity
through education etc etc these are the
reasons and they're all nice reasons
they're not nasty reasons but can we
really feed a population of nine billion
people which we will have by 2050 and
it'll peak according to the United
Nations median projection at about nine
point two nine point three in about 2070
then help me to that were bound to find
that's wrong either up or down but can
we really feed that number of people
well at the moment we need a large
proportion of the earth to feed six
point nine billion people so if we add
another two billion people and we asked
and we enable them to eat chickens and
pigs and all these things we like to eat
then we're going to don't need a lot
more land now it'd be nice to do all
this organically but the problem with
that is we're going to need a lot more
land for the cattle whose fertilizer is
going to be whose manure is going to be
used as fertilizer etc so we're going to
need even more land if we were using the
mostly organic farming technologies of
the 1950s today we would need
approximately twice as much land to
produce the same amount of food as we
produce today so let's not do that
and let's treble yields if we treble
yields in farming we could actually feed
nine billion people from a smaller
acreage than we feed six point nine
billion today
so can we treble yields well we've just
done it in the last sixty years we
trebled yields this is the yields of
rice wheat and maize the big three
cereal crops which provide about sixty
percent of human calories and they
traveled over that time
despite taking effectively no extra
acres under the plow nobody felt this
could be done
we were told repeatedly throughout this
period by environmentalists such as
Lester Brown that it could not be done
and yet it was done and how was it done
it was done by getting dwarfing genes
into wheat so that they put more of
their energy into seeds rather than
stalks it was done by the use of
machinery and chemicals and fertilizers
and all these things that raised raised
yields in farming and what that did was
it enabled us to well and and what first
thing he did was lit lowered food prices
and food prices have been on a long-term
decline now we've just heard that
they're high at the moment and some
people even talk about record highs but
if you correct for inflation these are
not record highs I mean this is roughly
where we're at at the moment that's
actually the 2008 spike but the 2010
spike is at about the same level as that
it's an uptick and it's causing real
pain but it's from a very low level and
what this means is that by increasing
yields we've actually been able to spare
land if you go in the woods of New
England you find stone fences like this
running through the landscape where
people used to have farms New England
used to be 70% farmland now it's 70%
woodland the more we can increase farm
yields the more land we can spare for
national parks and wildernesses there's
an interesting calculation done by a guy
called Helmut hobble in Vienna who with
splendid Teutonic precision has worked
out that human beings are eating 23.8%
of all the plant matter grown on the
earth each year that is to say of net
primary production and he's done the map
for different parts of the world and and
on the bottom graph you can see this in
the darker the area the more of the
primary production of the earth were
pinching for ourselves and our animals
but the top graph shows something
interesting it's what effect were having
on primary production are we raising or
lowering the productivity of plants and
it turns out that in some areas like
northern Europe you can't see it very
well on the chart we're actually raising
the product of
of the land of plants so much that even
though were pinching a big chunk of it
there's about as much left over for
nature as if we weren't here at all
and he says that it's quite feasible to
imagine a world in which we take more
than a quarter of the plant production
for our own use but that we so increase
the productivity of ecosystems through
fertilizers and irrigation and things
like that that actually there's just as
much left over for wildlife as before
but this of course depends on fuel it
depends upon tractors and gasoline and
diesel and gas and all these things that
agriculture depends upon aren't they
gonna run out well they haven't yet and
we've been saying they will for 150
years actually there are predictions
going right back to the 1860s of a coal
peak coal which was predicted by the
economist Jevons in 1860s leading to a
British Royal Commission on what to do
in the coal ran out that was in 1860 and
people like Jimmy Carter were saying
that Jimmy that that oil was going to
run out imminently in in the 1970s and
likewise the book limits to growth in
1970 projected that that we were headed
for a disaster because of lots of other
minerals lots of other elements and
metals and so on running out it didn't
happen minerals on the hill got more
abundant as we got more ingenious at
finding them and they got cheaper this
is the reduction in the price of metals
over the last few decades and centuries
and it's been a pretty spectacular
reduction in the affordability of all of
these metals and by the way we've just
had a revolution in energy that is
really quite extraordinary it's happened
in two years and it's all about shale
gas until two years ago we thought there
was perhaps 30 40 maybe 50 years of of
gas left in the world and that it would
would perhaps be the first of the fossil
fuels to run out that's now been turned
on the head on its head by the discovery
of enormous reserves of shale gas which
can be economically exploited exploited
at prices way down but
even the price of getting coal out
here's a shale gas drilling rig in
Pennsylvania producing shale gas and
this is an idea of just how much the
estimates of the amount of stuff have
changed in the world the International
Energy Agency estimates that there's 250
years worth of gas in the world now
that's quarter of a millennium that
surely is long enough for us to find an
alternative to fossil fuels if we need
to so the idea that agriculture can't
deliver because it can't because it's
going to run out of gas to make
fertilizer just no longer adds up and by
the way we do indeed need to get energy
from somewhere for civilization and
there are lots of ways of doing it this
is one to put gigantic windmills all
over the landscape and where mills do
produce electricity but it's worth just
putting it in perspective that's how
much a wind turbine produces per year
that's how much a single shale gas well
produces in a year and so which would
you rather have 48 of these for 25 years
which is their natural lifetime or one
of those for 30 days which is how long
it's there when it goes there's just a
Christmas tree apparatus on the ground
pumping the gas that's why I think it's
not at all obvious that renewables are
greener than fossil fuels because
renewables have other disadvantages too
here's a white tailed eagle killed by a
wind turbine in Norway 24 Golden Eagles
a year are killed by one wind farm in
California ah yes but aren't fossil
fuels going to bring a civilization to a
horrible halt by warming up the climate
well we don't know yet absolutely and
I'm the first to admit that I don't know
but I and yet to be persuaded that there
is something here that we should be
really immediately worried about or
alarmed about it's possible but it
doesn't look to me yet very convincing
we've seen a warming over the last 30
years this is the satellite data which
is roughly consistent with the ground
data it's it shows a slightly less of a
warming but it sees a warming of
low rate it's a rate of less than 0.1 of
a degree per decade it's nothing it's
very less than point two of a degree per
decade it's not nearly enough to get us
to two degrees per century which is the
sort of thing that the international
intergovernmental panel on climate
change talks about and we're seeing
other signs that the world is getting
warmer on sea level is definitely rising
although it's not showing any sign of
acceleration and it's been arising since
long before human impact started
Greenland it's rising by the way the sea
level at about the rate of a foot a
century and I think on the whole human
civilization can probably work out how
to cope with a foot a century Greenland
is indeed losing ice it's losing ice at
the rate of about 200 cubic kilometers a
year that's a large number put it in
perspective though it's less than half a
percent per century so Greenland will be
99.95% intact after a hundred years that
doesn't yet seem to me to be something
we need to worry about glaciers are
retreating yes but they have been since
the middle of the nineteenth century
since we started coming out of the
Little Ice Age there's no particular
evidence of an acceleration in recent
years due to human impact the frequency
of storms is roughly the same as it's
always been in fact it hit a record low
in the last year or so and we've now had
the global warming scare for long enough
to start to look back at some of the
predictions that were made about it at
the start and he is one that would Jim
Hansen produced in 1986 in which he drew
a number of lines depending on what we
did about carbon emissions and the top
line that you see is the one that will
happen he said if we don't do anything
about carbon emissions in fact our
carbon emissions have gone up faster
than in that assumption and yet this is
where the climate is this is where the
temperature has ended up way below all
of the lines so when people say that
global warming is happening worse than
predicted I simply don't know what
they're talking about it seems to me to
be happening less badly than predicted
now there's plenty of evidence that it
may accelerate etc etc we should be
concerned about it but I'm not yet
convinced that it's that it's going to
derail civilization
in fact there's plenty of evidence for
example the tree line in in in the Urals
is lower than it was in the Middle Ages
were not yet in uncharted territory in
terms of warmth even in this millennium
let alone in this interglacial period
and when we had a much warmer period
that's the interglacial we're just
coming out of the coldest part of it the
Little Ice Age back in the medieval lot
the Holocene optimum at 7,000 years ago
it was a good deal warmer that's when
the Sahara was Green and so on and this
is to me one of the most disturbing
things about the whole climate debate
because this is from a lecture given by
Richard Muller at Berkeley just recently
and it shows the effect of that
notorious email about using Mike's
nature trick to hide the decline this is
what was meant by this this is what the
tree-ring data shows a downward dip at
the end and watch what happens when you
use Mike's nature trick to hide the
decline so I think we're almost exactly
on course for a mild warming in this
century that is completely consistent
with a full greenhouse effect from
carbon dioxide but is not consistent
with the kinds of positive feedbacks
that are built into the most of the
models and that predict a 3 or 4 degree
warming but even if it does happen are
we really sure that it's going to that
we're not going to be able to cope with
it as a civilization after all we've had
warming in the 20th century and
something like malaria actually
retreated dramatically during this
century the graphs show where malaria
was in 1900 and where it is today and
the blue chart at the bottom the blue on
the chart at the bottom shows where
malaria has retreated the red on the
chart at the bottom shows where malaria
is getting worse now malaria didn't
retreat because we did something about
the climate malaria retreated because we
did something about human living human
behavior human living standards human
technology human infrastructure we
basically went indoors at night and
close the windows and things like that
and we we defeated mosquitos in all
sorts of different ways the number of
death
from extreme weather that is to say
floods droughts and storms is 93 percent
lower than it was in the 1920s the
probability of dying in extreme weather
is 98 percent down from what it was in
the nineteen twenties this isn't because
storms have got less dangerous it's
because we're better at defending
against storms and droughts and floods
were better at making sure food gets to
people in droughts were better at at
communicating and transporting people
and we're better at defending ourselves
generally and I think that's likely to
continue even with quite severe warming
in the next decade and it's worth
remembering that the more carbon dioxide
we put in the atmosphere the faster our
crops are going to grow the rate at
which crops grow depends on on the
ambient concentration of carbon dioxide
and that's what a plant looks like grown
in 750 parts per million of carbon
dioxide and that means that plants have
less demand for water and things like
that so actually they'll be able to
survive droughts better besides we are
actually progressively decarbonizing our
economy we're not doing it fast enough
perhaps but we are doing it we've been
doing it for 150 years not because of
policy but because of technology as we
shifted from wood to coal to oil to gas
we shifted from a high carbon low
hydrogen fuel to a high hydrogen low
carbon fuel and we're on track to have
about 90 percent hydrogen and 10 percent
carbon in our fuel mix sometime around
the late 21st century well I've given
you some reasons why I on the hill think
that this century is going to be great
and that most of the worries we have
about it are overblown I'm certainly not
saying that bad things won't happen
there will be Wars I don't think will
extinguish Wars there will be natural
disasters that will be man-made
disasters there will be dictators there
will be idiotic things done by human
beings we always will do things like
that but isn't it necessary to be
pessimistic isn't it a better idea to be
cautious and worried because then we can
solve our problems well
Ashley I don't think so Archimedes when
he set out to solve problems wasn't he
was living in the richest part of the
world at the time in ancient Greece and
he was the most out in the most
ambitious civilization on the planet not
the most worried civilization on the
planet you can say the same of
al-khwarizmi in arabia and Fibonacci in
Renaissance Italy and George Stevenson
in Victorian Britain and Thomas Edison
in in in in 19th century America and
Steve Jobs today each of them lives in
the richest place in the world at the
time and in the place with the most
ambition and then place with the most
optimism and the place with the most
hope you don't get innovation out of
despair there isn't a lot of software
innovation going on in Zimbabwe at the
moment well isn't it complacent to be an
optimist
isn't that a sin well I don't think so I
actually think that what is complacent
is to think that today's technologies
are good enough and that we can't do
better and to think that if we that we
should prevent genetically modified food
because we think pesticides are ok as
they are I think it's better to move
forward in technology and that is
actually a less complacent view of the
world and as for policies based on
pessimism here's one based on climate
pessimism we're taking five percent of
the world maize crop and turning it into
ethanol in order to fill our cars with
ethanol and that's had the effect of
reducing displacing about 0.6% of world
fuel so even if we took half the maize
crop and turned it into ethanol we'd
still only displace 6% of world oil use
and we're doing it at the expense of
increasing world food prices and
therefore making hunger worse in
countries I simply don't see that the
pessimism that base that is based on
this that drives this policy is
justified in fact I think that the story
of history and humanity says that we can
actually we do actually do more for less
that if we have higher
yields it means we destroy less
rainforests because we don't need so
much land if we have new technology we
actually use less resources we we
actually become more efficient in the
way we our technology works if we use
gas and nuclear power and things like
that then we won't need to sacrifice the
landscape to renewable energy if we make
more wealth then we will have less
environmental loss there's the thing
called the environmental Kuznets curve
which predicts the level of income at
which countries start to care about the
environment and above that level of
income they start to do dramatic things
like reforesting and demanding clean air
laws and things like that countries like
China are reaching that point at the
moment and here we are doing more for
less producing more prosperity for less
energy progressively every year not just
in the Western world but in all in in
China and in Russia and in India as well
well this is the nightmare that we often
hear expressed in this case by Ban
ki-moon that the world's current
economic model is an environmental
global suicide pact that will result in
disaster if it isn't reformed that we
need a revolution on how to bec make it
more sustainable and here's the opposite
view that if we had a strong commitment
to market-based solutions international
mobility of people ideas and technology
the global economy expanding at an
average rate of 3% so the global average
income reached 21,000 dollars by 1950 in
today's dollars that there would be
great improvement in overall health and
social conditions of the majority of
people energy and mineral resources
would be abundant because of rapid
technological progress which both reduce
the resources needed to produce a given
level of output and increases the
economically recoverable reserves
resulting in rapid technological
progress which would free natural
resources currently devoted to the
provision of human needs for other
purposes increasing ecologic but these
aren't my words these are words that
come from a document put out by Ban
ki-moon's
own organization the United Nations to
describe one of the economic scenarios
used in the Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate
change projections of what's going to
happen in the future this is the
high-growth model this is how they
describe it and I think they may have a
point here that actually the rich and we
get the more we can cope with
environmental problems sustainability
after all is development that meets the
needs of the present without
compromising the ability of future
generations to meet their own needs I'm
not convinced much as I love local
production self-sufficiency no
technology low growth organic farming
and renewable energy I'm perfectly happy
with these things in my own life but I'm
not convinced that they are going to be
as good for the world as trade
specialization high technology high
growth intensive farming and lots of
natural gas that in fact the old poll
Ehrlich idea that the impact of human
beings on the planet
is proportional to population times
affluence times technology I think is
wrong I think the evidence suggests that
it's more like this that the impact is
indeed proportional to population but
that divided by affluence and technology
that the richer and more technological
we get the lesser impact on the planet
well let me end with this quotation we
cannot absolutely prove that those are
in error who say Society has reached a
turning point that we have seen our best
days but so said all who came before us
and with just as much apparent reason on
what principle is it that with nothing
but improvement behind us we were to
expect nothing but deterioration before
us
well that wasn't said by me or someone
like me recently that was said by thomas
babington macaulay
the historian in 1830 this was just
before living standards of working
people in britain began their
extraordinary historic rise for the
first time as a result of the Industrial
Revolution this was before Britain even
started really getting rich and yet he
was already fed up with pessimists
saying it cannot get better than this
with pessimists essentially being
complacent so I think in going from the
self-sufficiency of the Australian
hand-axe to the networked brain of the
computer app
we have actually given ourselves an
extraordinarily bright future thank you
very much
[Applause]
ha
[Laughter]
Gordon Gaurav asks was acid rain a false
alarm or was it a case of addressing a
potential problem and changing our
behavior to deal with the problem a
little bit of both
acid rain certainly existed I mean there
was no question about the acidification
of the rain but you guys caused it for
Europe as I remember we Brits probably
yes because of the prevailing wind or
something or yeah coal yes you're right
I covered that story for The Economist
so several several years and I gradually
became more and more cynical about it
not about the fact that rain was
acidified and not entirely about the
acidification of fresh water there was
indeed an issue there but the forests
death just didn't happen and it didn't
it wasn't the wood that we change the
policy and that prevented it happen it
just didn't happen the biomass of
forests was increasing in the 1980s
before we passed any laws this was true
in America and it was true in Europe and
the great big nae PAP national
acidification precipitous it if I'd
precipitation assessment panel mm-hm
which got it for you that's close which
I think Congress authorized came to the
conclusion that there was no death of
trees as a result of rain acidification
at all so I think it was largely a false
alarm because it was forest death that
was one that caught the people's
imagination etc now the war acidified
lakes but again nay pap concluded that
four percent of lakes were acidified
instead of fifty percent which was the
early estimate so it was an exaggeration
rather than a total false alarm it's
just gonna be one of those subjects
where you say that actually acid rain
was good for us well
nitric acid is a fertilizer aha and
there is no question that nitrogen you
that there was a slight increase in the
rate of growth of trees in places like
Sweden and Germany in the 1980s at the
time they were all supposed to be dying
it's probably because of the nitric acid
from the fumes from cars and petrol
stations power stations now I'm not
saying that it's wrong to have got rid
of sulfur emissions from power plants
and to you know done something about
nitrogen emissions from cars because
there are all sorts of other problems I
mean local emissions of sulfur dioxide
can indeed do real harm and and of
course local emissions of nitrogen
oxides from cars can cause urban smog
and things like that so I'm all for
doing something about it but the idea
that you know all conifer forests in
Germany will be gone by the year 2000
German Ministry of the Interior 1983 not
true it just you know it was nothing
like true here's one from the other side
it's kind of it uncredited can we
sustain growth of progress with fewer
and fewer people every year after 2070
is it a coincidence that all progress
seems to mirror population curves going
up I think that's a really interesting
question and I have a sneaking feeling
that my optimism may be a little wrong
in that in that one in that I do think
it seems to be harder to keep innovating
in societies that have small numbers of
young people that that you know part of
the reason Japan just couldn't keep the
gig going in the last two decades was
because its population just became so
top-heavy with old people now nothing
wrong with I mean you know I'm nearly as
old as used to you know you know I'm you
know I still think we're both
open-minded sort of people but it
nonetheless is true that there's a
demographic sweet spot that coincides
with rapid economic growth it's when
you've had a huge population boom so
you've got a long young people
but those young people themselves are
having fewer babies so you actually get
this sort of bulge of workers with not
very many dependent children and not
very many dependent elderly and that's
where Asia was for most of the last two
decades and that's where Africa funnily
enough is going to be in the next decade
interestingly so it's possible that when
we're all declining you know when
population is literally going down in
every most countries in the world and
the world on average it's possible that
we will not be able to sustain the kinds
of rates of innovation and rates of
growth that will keep us on track for
these kind of futures but I think I'd
rather live in a world with them not
that it's my choice but with you know 9
billion people in a slower growth rate
than 30 billion people and a faster
growth rate let's look at it even not
only population curves going up and down
at the organization so for the next 30
years the developing world
has got the most enormous cities with
what you would probably call the richest
social capital the most sexual exchange
of ideas going on at any time in history
presumably amongst populations that are
basically very young just as you
described them and so for a period of
time now the next 30 years the global
north where we live we live is pretty
much old cities full of old people
increasingly and the rest of the world
is the largest cities in the world by
far now except for Tokyo or places like
Mumbai and Lagos and Khan so on Mexico
City and this is where all the young
people in the world are now what we've
worked sometimes in national security
people and they'll say young people
equals and young males and China equals
basically young soldiers or criminals
yeah well when you're national security
everything looks like a soldier or a
criminal but
for the rest of us it looks like a
competition they want our jobs and
they're getting them they're making our
stuff how does that play over 30 years
because after 30 years with their birth
rate going down in all these places what
I hadn't gotten until I read Fred
Pierce's book the coming population
crash is that once the society ages and
the population pyramid stops looking
like this and it looks like that it
states that way and so this there's this
last boom of young people that we get in
the global South and the developing
world over the next 30 years and then
other things being equal stabilizes so
given all that and given your theories
how does this next 30 years play out
well short answer is I haven't the
foggiest and I learned from people like
you in in particularly in this
urbanisation point where I think you've
done some amazingly interesting analyses
Stewart so if you don't know they're not
anything I know but I think is it really
I mean when you think about
entrepreneurship you have to be an
irrational fool to be an entrepreneur
you've got to believe that in some sense
you've got many irrational fool
entrepreneurs are in this audience I've
got to believe you got hot bear that
exactly and good for you and thank you
because you've got to believe you can
beat the odds and maybe the odds get a
little better when there's fewer people
trying to do it but most of us are
sitting around watching TV the
relatively few young people can have a
slightly better chance of pulling off an
entrepreneurial success
so maybe the incentives are still there
or even though there's not so many of us
I think it is I mean I'm not yet at the
point where I where I think that a
shrinking population is going to be a
disaster because after all you know
let's say Japan's future is what we've
got
in other words stagnation economically
for
few decades its stagnation at a pretty
high level of standard of living you
know it's not exactly misery in Japan it
is in parts of Japan this week but you
know it's not that bad a future so I
still see it as a bit of a soft landing
on population and on entrepreneurship
and that kind of thing
but I think it's possible that that
might dent the acceleration of growth
that I'm talking about there's a
question anonymous what should the
progressive movement learn from your
worldview in fact take it apart a little
bit who pays attention to you
conservatives or progressives and what
do they do with what you tell them well
funny enough conservatives don't like my
line either because that terribly
pessimistic they you know they think the
government's driving everything to
disaster and progressives don't like it
because I say that it's the market not
the government that's going to sort us
out but if you take the strict meaning
of the word progressive I think I am a
progressive I and I'm hugely in favor of
progress I'd like to see more of it I
think it's it's a good thing but in some
sense progressive has come to mean
believing in top-down solutions
believing that you you you you see a
problem and you go in and you enact a
policy to deal with it what I'm talking
about is is how an awful lot of these
solutions are sort of bottom-up and
that's more amenable to so-called
conservatives or at least free-market
people who and there's a very nice
analysis that a guy called brink Lindsey
has done of the culture wars of the
sixties and seventies I think captures
this political point quite well he says
that look what happened was there was
enormous economic growth it led to
social liberal liberation it led to
essentially the women's movement civil
rights all these kind of things the left
liked the results but hated the
mechanism that produced it the right
loved the mechanism and hated the
results
umm I like both okay
related that Alexander Rose asked most
of the emissions cleanup that you
mentioned comes from government laws not
market forces but I don't see much
mention of this do we still need
government please yes of course we still
need government I mean for a start we
need to decide which side of the road
we're going to drive on etc etc you know
there's all sorts of things that
wouldn't work if we didn't have some
kind of enforcement and a man with a man
with a gun at the back of the room is is
still necessary if that's what
government is in the end is sort of
still necessary you got a knife from the
government I'm here to help well you
know I mean the monopolization of force
is great because it means that you don't
have to do the force yourself you know I
see that one of the great benefits of
government is that is that it will take
revenge on my behalf if a crime is
committed against me I don't have to go
ahead and you know have a vendetta that
kind of thing so I've got a long way
from air pollution have no you're
absolutely right air pollution laws have
helped although you know technology was
improving it before and if you look at
water purity standards funnily enough
there you can hardly see the effect of
laws the graph just continues it's sort
of the same rate when they come in so
it's quite a lot of it would have
happened anyway because of common law
and lawsuits and people saying you know
I stopped polluting my stream etc but I
I have no problem with saying that let's
get government to sort out some of these
problems in your book you say of
government should tax carbon yes I'm not
sure I still think that
what I meant by that was look there's a
possibility that garden is a big problem
and therefore we should do our best to
discourage its use and in the good old
pigouvian sense you know if you want to
discourage you to tax it doing something
my problem really is that now that we've
seen well there are two problems one is
that if you actually look at what I pay
for the diesel I put in my car in
England about 2/3 of it I think goes to
the government as tax or maybe a third
icon remember but a big chunk of it and
then let's look free here to you yeah I
did and yesterday I filled up my
mother-in-law's car in Houston and I
prepaid and ended up overpaying I
couldn't fill the tank because it was so
cheap but I didn't know what to do about
that by the way and but anyway that the
point is that if you go to Nick Stearns
report on the damage done by likely to
be done by climate change and you take
his assumptions which are extreme
assumptions he assumes extremely high
rates of warming extremely extremely
high rates of damage from warming higher
than most of the models accept and he
assumes no discount rate so he says we
should be paying for it now rather than
waiting to pay for it when we're richer
and take those assumptions he comes out
and he says basically we should be
paying 80 pounds of ton eighty dollars a
tonne carbon tax well you run through
the calculation when I fill my diesel
it's actually about it's higher than
that already so in that sense we're
already taxing carbon through these
various fuel duties as well no you also
run a coal mine do you get taxed for at
the as the mine for your carbon no
you're right that that that you know
carbon
I mean coal is under taxed I think you
know it does more damage to the
environment etc
as you say on my land in the northern
England there is a coal mine and I make
some green coal mines cool the visit all
I've done it
he lives in Newcastle coals to Newcastle
is because coals came from Newcastle
from his ancestors the Industrial
Revolution got going why he likes it so
much yeah I do guys did it well I'm very
I'll give this one ancestor who was the
first person to put a steam engine in a
coal mine in at 1714 to pump water out
of out of mine that had ruined three
other people and he made it pay that was
it that was the elbow and all those true
he was the elbow he was the one man who
started the whole thing
and and if you think about it you know
it was a pretty wonderful thing to get
cheap energy to people it meant that
they could clothe themselves and feed
themselves much more cheaply it meant
that essentially well you stopped
deforesting england for one cell that's
right I mean if we hadn't happened on
coal in England we'd have DeForest still
by by 1830 we were using as much coal as
wood would come from forests twice the
size of England you had already DeForest
it Scotland at that point which hasn't
come back yet indeed you know may it may
indeed yes exactly but you know if we
carbon dioxide those trees will grow
faster right that's right a little bit a
little bit beavers are coming back Russ
guys a zoologist remember just talk
about a bird or an animal a space to get
happy improvement in growth rates of
wheat and doubled carbon dioxide that's
other things being equal and it might
not be achievable etc but it's a non-si
it's a non not insignificant point that
often gets forgotten in the debate I'm
not saying we should have more carbon
notes that have definitely not that
nutty but and you know my self-interest
says that I should not want carbon tax
because I have a financial interest in
mining but I do think that we should do
something about cono so I'm just not
quite convinced that a carbon taxes is
necessarily going to be
the right way of doing it it's better
than cap-and-trade which seems to me too
easy to gain politically I used to love
cap-and-trade when it was done for the
acid rain thing I thought it was
brilliantly done you know the sulfur
cap-and-trade worked really well
it got self remissions down faster and
cheaper than the command-and-control
would have done but that's because there
were relatively few actors and in in the
market the problem of how to allocate
carbon credits in a political system
where everybody wants a favor is just
too difficult so a carbon tax is better
than that I think and I think if you can
make a carbon tax revenue neutral this
was the argument in the book ok I'm
reconvince in myself here if you can
make a carbon tax revenue neutral in
other words you say we're going to cut
other taxes mm-hmm so that then you can
make it politically acceptable and it's
not a bad idea to tax Co which other
taxes would you cut to match the carbon
tax that you would increase well ones
that prevent job creation basically so
payroll taxes say for example you know
ones that prevent employers taking
people on fair enough talking about
energy everybody's talking about nuclear
this week yeah and your and my nemesis
George Monbiot the columnist commentator
for the Guardian announced that this
week he has gone from being anti-nuclear
he's been sort of neutral about nuclear
and last couple years and now thanks to
you Fukushima he is absolutely
pro-nuclear because well justified and
so you seen the worst that could happen
it wasn't that bad he realizes all
renewables if they add up will basically
decimate England there's not enough
place for all those wind collectors and
some collectors and hell let's just do
news what the hell do we make of that
this is a guy who thinks you and I are
the devil in common yes well second
guessing George Monbiot brain is not
something I'm any good at I'd rather
talk about nuclear power I'm a nuke warm
lukewarm nuclear person I sort of like
it but I'm not wholly convinced and of
course you know being a contrarian sort
of guy I love the safety I think it's an
incredibly safe technology and you know
look at Chernobyl we put the stupidest
regime in charge of the stupidest design
you can think of and they killed 54
people on the day which is pretty
horrible maybe 4,000 extra cancers no
Bextra birth defects the data is pretty
clear on that I think you know agreed on
that compare that with the death rate
you know 20,000 people may die in
Chinese coal mines every year and 29
people were entombed in a coal mine in
New Zealand the other day fossil fuels
kill a lot more people than that so in
safety terms I think there's no question
nuclear nuclear great even with the risk
of accidents etc etc my problem is
economic I just think that the costs of
nuclear are not going to be able to
compete particularly with shale gas and
let's protect them unless we tax yeah
but you've got a this is back to my
point about the fuel duty you could tax
the bejesus out of it before you really
make a difference and at the moment
there's a nuclear reactor being built in
Finland and it's running about 50
percent over budget and four years
behind schedule and it it's going to
come in at the sort of cost per kilowatt
hour that that is far more expensive
than coal and gas and it's what the
other thing about nuclear is they're
kind of great big monstrous things that
you know a top-down design by sort of
bureaucrats and they're 2 gigawatts in
size or what it's just big computer mice
they're big computer mice yeah you're
right
but they're making them smaller now is
that ok yeah that's great I like I agree
I think these modular kind of new
batteries that you put in a town for 25
years and they kind of run themselves
and the ones with the passive safety
stuff is fantastic
and as you know I'm getting quite
interested in this thorium technology
although I don't understand why near
thorium reactors how many thorium
enthusiasts are in this group there tend
to be groups of people who are on your
side in this metal designs we convert
thorium as a nuclear fuel compared with
uranium has several advantages it's it's
more abundant it can't do a chain
reaction on its own you have to put the
neutrons in so it's inherently safe in
that sense it can't produce plutonium so
none of its waste can be used for
bomb-making it's waste is it basically
has to be stored for centuries rather
than millennia because it's
radioactivity declines much faster and
it can be used in a liquid form in the
fuel instead of a solid fuel instead of
fuel rods you know these things in
zirconium you actually have a Multan
salt of this stuff which is the fuel and
you dope that with enough uranium-235 to
produce the nuke to provide the neutrons
and then you get the thorium turns to
u-233 and then that fits it for sales
and you get officials also it and you
get the the actually activity there now
the US Air Force was very keen on this
and it wanted to build a nuclear
aeroplane I didn't know that in the
early 1960s and that program got killed
and that's probably just as well but I
just sort of hoped that the Fukushima
accident gives us a chance to go back
and look at all these technologies and
say you know is the pressurized water
reactor which after all is inherently
unsafe in the sense that if you if you
let it get too hot the water turns to
steam and it once and steam has less
cooling properties than the mortar does
because it's a gas rather than the
liquid so you know it's inherently
unstable let's go back and find an
inherently stable nuclear technology and
and go back to the drawing board and try
and start from scratch so you'd like to
see it sounds like a renaissance not
just in nuclear business by nuclear
design yeah and one of the problems is
as I understand it you can
come a nuclear engineer and go through a
huge amount of education and training
and you hardly hear the word liquid fuel
you know what I mean it's such a sort of
side technology that everything is
there's a tremendous sort of vested
interest in in an existing entrenched
incumbent technology and it's very hard
to to turn an industry round in a
different direction but maybe this is a
chance to do that climate change may
make it happen if it happens if it
happens Jack Kragen tells your question
you know in your book you suggest that
locally grown food is not necessarily
greener than food grown far away and
transported can you explain this
here in artisanal food country yeah I
mean I mean the lion's den a bit on this
one that's come with us to the farmers
market yes I love ladies growing food
and you know you sell something from
from off my farm etc but I think on the
whole it's a luxury rather than being
good for the planet it's something that
we can afford to do because we're rich
rather than something we should do for
the poor and here's why if you add up
the the energy costs of transport of
food freely no green beans from Africa
to my plate in in England about four
percent is the frating it from Africa
about 40 percent of me driving to the
store and getting it well that's going
to be there whether it's local food or
not and and the the the real advantage
there is isn't it wonderful that I can
support an African farmer by buying his
produce and I think that's the the key
argument that you know we we we in
Europe have these gigantic tariff
barriers against food produced in Africa
one of the consequences of which is that
there is a thriving market in
agricultural produce coming to London
from Kenya it's not food it's cut
flowers why is that because it doesn't
hit the agricultural tariff barrier
because it's not food you sure I mean
it's it's just bonkers that were
discriminate now as a
if we had free trade in the world I'd
probably be bust because my costs are
too high in Europe but I'd rather that
than then continuing to be unfair on the
rest of the world I think you grow what
you what you're good at where you can in
the world as efficiently as you can and
you use less land doing it you know I
don't if I had to grow bananas in in
north of England I would I could do it I
take a lot of energy no I'd rather the
bananas were grown in Africa or the
Caribbean or something and they didn't
try and grow wheat in the Caribbean we
grew weak where we were and we swapped
we're both bit of global warming all I
have to do is wait a while and you can
grow up in a nursing do you know which
country grows the most bananas in Europe
no Iceland explain that one
she cheapest greenhouses cuz yeah Kevin
Kelly just brought up his own question
what are you worried about
second question were you Austin optimist
was there a trigger and start with the
person what are you worried about and
then let's get the history of your sunny
disposition religious fundamentalism is
the short answer
that's Kevin not you sorry is IJ he's a
Christian I think he isn't but I don't
know I wouldn't describe it as I
describe myself as an au ologist but I
was brought up as a as an Anglican but
that's the mildest form of the virus
it's really a vaccine
the what what worries me is the
demography of religious fundamentalism
in other words in Catholicism and
Protestantism in is in Islam in Judaism
the the extremists are having more
babies than the moderates the this is
quite a striking phenomenon that's going
down though is that okay in all in the
image even Mormons are having fewer kids
is that right thank you I need to stop
worrying I can be an optimist again what
are you worried about come on I'm
worried about the fact that we shut down
the world economy very nearly for good
in the 1100s when China went all sort of
superstitious Arabia burnt all its books
and turned its back on freedom of
inquiry the Medieval Renaissance based
around the University of Paris and
Abelard and Heloise and people like that
was shut down by a thug called bernard
of clairvaux
we came close to extinguishing the flame
in that century now luckily there was a
bunch of tuscan merchants and people
like Fibonacci I was going across to
North Africa and picking up ideas like
zero and Indian numerals and things like
that who kept the flame alive now if the
if the what's the word I'm looking for
if the bigots got hold of the entire
world could they shut it down for good
I don't think so but I do occasionally
worry about it your second question was
have I always been an optimist and the
answer is no I back in the 70s when I
was at university I was a standard
environmental ultra pessimist and I
thought I genuinely I knew good to get
that from who are you paying attention I
got it from EF Schumacher and
you know all those kind of he was the
British version limits to you did it
here as well believe me did he yes
exactly
Annie and everyone I know yeah I I
thought that well I'm not gonna live as
long as my parents because of this
cancer epidemic caused by pesticides so
I need to sort of kind of enjoy myself
while I can but there's no much fun
getting a proper job because my
country's in decline economically and
it's all gonna get worse and you
remember yeah this is we were brushing
our teeth in the dark you know and all
that you remember that or you probably
did remember that but the hippies freeze
in the dark was a British war Minister
of Energy said you know advised us to
brush our teeth in the dark to save
electricity and during the oil crisis
now it's our with a friend also yes and
so so economically environmentally the
the the health-wise I just thought it
was gonna get worse and worse and I
realized about the age of 21 that nobody
ever said anything to me optimistic
about the inter about the planet that I
could remember not even in a pub you
know and so I was really taken by
surprise when London had this boom in
the 80s and everybody got rich and I
started flashing around the champagne
and things like that
I thought Helen I thought it's not
supposed to happen is supposed to be
declined I genuinely believed that I was
economically illiterate I was a
zoologist I lived in my own little
bubble and I just I just all I remember
the newspapers and they said
everything's getting worse and I thought
so so for me this is a Damascene
conversion I mean I'm a sort of zeal of
the apostate type here I'm sorry
back to religious imagery was okay with
you know people always ask and I'll ask
was it a moment or was it a year or was
it a particular offer or what got you
it was dribble dribble dribble little
bits and pieces here and that but I
would say if I want to give one name of
someone who at first I thought was
talking nonsense and then I gradually
realized it wasn't it was Julian Simon
another one yeah his bet with Paul
Ehrlich and all that
didn't really know about the bet to
start with I mean I I read the ultimate
resource I guess that have the better in
it I can't remember those but but it's a
gradual thing you know you change your
mind and and he said what I did was I
started sort of looking I was a
newspaper columnist in the late 90s and
and and I a seed rain thing had had had
a big impact on me because I'd realized
actually you know a lot of the stuff I
wrote about that about how all the
forests were in trouble and nothing
could be done about it and actually
nonsense and I began to get a bit you
know began to question other things etc
and I started writing contrarian columns
about things and and then you start
seeking out the evidence and you I think
I've always tried to falsify my views of
course not none of us do were all
subject to confirmation bias but but the
the - during the writing of this book I
literally went out and I sought out
issues where I thought okay well this is
banter you know I can't happiness was
one I thought happiness was an issue
where I was going to have to concede
yeah okay we're getting Richard but
we're not getting happier but I'd rather
you know have a flush toilet and be
unhappy than have a no flush toilet and
be unhappy
you know happiness isn't everything was
what I thought I was going to have
um but actually hated so for me it was
quite a moment when I came across the
the lit the new literature on happiness
and discovered that the easterland
paradox had been largely refuted and
that actually there is good evidence of
a correlation between happiness and
income okay so your there's some career
things going on during it so you got a
PhD in zoology were you a practicing
zoologist that makes it sound like sex
life of birds and what I did was I
attached radio transmitters to pheasants
to try and work out who the male's made
it with which male made it with which
female in this kinda thing it's a
polygamous bird it's very unusual bird
for being polygamist most mammals are
polygamous most birds and monogamous so
why is this an exception and what does
it tell you about the evolution of
polygamy monogamy the evolution of
mating systems it was a wonderful thing
to spend three years doing as completely
cetera completely useless for the world
I can't believe I got a grant to do it
but there you go
it was fun from the government from the
government so a couple years later
you're an editor at the Economist which
presumably there's not that many PhD
zoologists on the staff there well
funnily enough my successor but to a
science editor was in the same zoology
department at the same university as me
Jeff Kerry still the son said there you
go
so he was presumably very excited pay
was definitely better I decided I wanted
to become a journalist rather than a
scientist because I wanted to be a mile
wide and an inch deep rather than the
other way around and I you know I just -
I've got the attention span of a
mosquito and I you know wanted to
satisfy it and so I started applying - I
applied to the BBC number other jobs etc
and then I got a job at the Economist
because the science editor had died and
they were looking for a new science
correspondent the science correspondent
become the science editor and they taken
on one intern they wants to take it on
another to sort of see which one worked
out and it worked out for me and not for
Adrian so they're waiting you never
studied journalism
you didn't even major in English that's
true how the hell did you become a
journalist I trained on the job
apprenticeship good old-fashioned way
you know I mean The Economist was
remember the great thing about The
Economist everything gets edited to hell
before it goes out and so you write some
dreadful piece of copy and it gets
mangled and you you learn from that and
you start so so it's a very collective
product in that sense editors as
teachers I like it
and and then as I'd only been there 11
months when the next when the then
science editor died this is all very
biological I didn't do it I promise
there were both wonderful people and
yeah Richard casement smoke this is a
coincidence that your seniors kept dying
well I was the first person to edit the
science section of The Economist and
live there are two or three of us now
okay so you bring your scientific
perspective and your biological
perspective to a journalistic job where
it's an economist the economy is stuff
you're looking at now ecology and is
said to blend with economics in some
fashion is that actually the case I
think there was a wonderful parallel and
it was one I was very interested in not
so much the ecology as the evolution the
evolutionary view of the world teaches
you a about emergent properties teaches
you about spontaneous order teaches you
about nobody being in charge you know
there's no master gene in the genome
there's no there's no master species in
the ecosystem what you see is a pattern
and an ordered pattern but it emerged
from below it didn't get ordained from
above and for me economics was very
similar understanding why certain
products took over the world when others
didn't was not about deciding whose
policy had decided that we're all going
to buy iPhones this year but but about
the bottom-up emergence of through
competition through natural selection if
you like credibly close parallels and of
course actually intellectually they come
from the same part of the Scottish
enlightenment I mean it's no accident
that Charles Darwin was reading out of
Smith at university etc the
the this idea that when you no longer
consider God to be in charge you start
to get the idea of spontaneous order and
it comes from David Hume and Adam Smith
and Charles Darwin it's the same idea
appearing in different fields these are
all Protestants is that an accident well
they weren't listening to a Provost
arguing with lots of other kinds of
dition sort of like Dennis taught as a
Catholic that's a good one I mean ethnic
Charles Darwin was a nonconformist
background you know what was it you know
that you know there's a good as Herman
Kahn says Unitarians believed in at most
one God yeah was it the Unitarian
terrorists burned a question mark into
someone's lawn we also you gonna hear
Unitarian jokes and and I am I wrote a
biography later of Francis Crick the
great for the book on right which I
didn't wrote a book about and and Crick
was a well he was parents were
Congregationalists when he was born but
they had been Unitarians they kind of
switched church and again you know
there's a little bit of a streak there
there's an open-mindedness about
nonconformist Protestants that that
helps but I'm not convinced that it's
the only thing that counts
there is ya know I was going to tell a
joke but it's a bit involved
okay for engineers in a bar you know
this one genetic engineer says God is a
genetic engineer why I've looked in the
genome that was done by a genetic
engineer like me second one says no
you're wrong God is a mechanical
engineer
I'm mechanical engineer I tell you that
skeleton was built by a mechanical
engineer the third one says now you're
both wrong I'm an electrical engineer
that brain was built by an electrical
engineer God is an electrical engineer
and the fourth one says you're all wrong
God is a civil engineer how do I know
I'm a civil engineer who else would put
a waste disposal pipe through a
recreational area and it can again it
gets to the point of unintelligent
design
that's why intelligent design is wrong
because it's not intelligent is it it's
clearly not intelligent design I'd love
to finish with that but I won't finish
for the question
won't be answered this year but will be
answered this century and it's the the
question which keeps coming up in
relation to markets and top-down and
bottom-up and so on which is the
question of China
so here's China top-down as it can be
and people I know who work with training
and various things where they're trying
to do really green cities are trying to
do nuclear they're trying to do genetic
engineering they're trained do this that
and everything it's full speed ahead
with amazing sophistication and serious
money now it's not only top-down it has
this other peculiar quality which is
that so far the Politburo in China and
all of the senior officers have
retrained others engineers or scientists
and they are now in competition with
nations like the United States and
Britain and India for that matter which
were nations run by lawyers who's gonna
win you show India's run by lawyers I've
got a feeling that take that one off my
ignorance right but you're right I mean
the current Britta Marika's run by
lawyers I can tell you that the current
British cabinet doesn't have a single
scientifically trained person in it I
think that's kind of depressing but
leaving that point aside and I
completely agree no doubt saying this
versus bottom-up who goes you know
versus chaotic yeah I don't think of
lawyers as bottom-up people I think of
them as top-down people but but let me
just just come back at you on China
because I'm not convinced it is at that
that at that top-down a place what
happens when you have a Maoist Society
is that everything is top down and when
suddenly dunk shopping comes along and
says Communist Party's still in charge
but you can do anything you want
suddenly you're putting a bottom-up
system in place topped out in other
words you're stripping away all
authority except the Communist Party on
top so you're taking away all the
intermediate layers all the all the the
the layers of government that get in the
way of people doing things are gone in
China it's an incredibly free place to
be an entrepreneur
unless you cross the Communist Party
which case you're in deep trouble so
basically I would argue that with one
exception it's actually rather a
bottom-up place and of course the other
thing down shopping does is remove
tariff barriers and give it the the most
free trade the most economically open
economy pretty well in the world and
that makes a huge difference so I don't
think China is an exception to this rule
now where I will agree with you is that
I can't see that regime adjusting
gracefully to put it that way you know
and and I think it's brittle politically
yeah at some point there's gonna have to
be an almighty political earthquake to
get the Communist Party out the way and
that could mess things up terribly for
the economy as well as friendly as
whereas India for all its corruption etc
is a sufficient democracy to you know to
have small earthquakes rather than big
ones as it as it adjusts so I do think
that you know the Communist Party regime
is a problem and it is a brutal and
horrible regime I'm not I'm not
apologizing for it but I also think that
that's a much freer society for
entrepreneurs to operate in the new make
out so net net this is the lead-in to
the next time sorry can I just ask you
one question yeah if if your publisher
and maybe this happened to you you know
Chinese publisher Chinese translation
publisher I guess this one you know said
we want to take out two pages on the
history of China before we publish the
book do you say yes or no mm I'd felt
even looked very closely at what two
pages basically a lot of rude remarks
about Ming Emperor's was mainly buddy
went but there was the odd dig at Mao in
there as well so if you face this and
what did you say I ended up saying yes I
went to talk to a lot of people I talked
to and you know professors of Chinese
blah blah blah etc and because I didn't
want to I I felt the principle was
important
but what they explained to me was look
it's your publisher whose self
self-censoring here because he goes to
jail if he publishes your book and the
regime doesn't like it so he's got to go
through your book and say I don't think
I can publish that page because I'll go
to jail and in the end if they're only
taking out two pages sure they'll miss
out on some juicy stories about Ming
Emperor's but they'll get the point I
would go for it for you you know so a
little difficulty they could probably
find it on Google Books anyway if they
want to see the expertise yeah
anyway I hope that was the right thing
to do so this leads into next month's
talk from Ian Morris why the West rules
for now and it sounds like your bet is
that China is brittle and will not rule
by mid-century put your money on India
your money on India how about India
versus Europe North America well forget
Europe we're we're a sideshow for the
next hundred years we're comfortable
sideshow you know all right but and
we're gonna get a ton of innovations but
they're gonna come from places like
China and India you know I mean you know
I've will get lovely new pharmaceuticals
to keep us healthy in our old age but
they'll have been invented somewhere
else and that's not entirely true of
course entrepreneurship can happen in
Europe but nothing it's no and it's hard
it is it's gonna be hard and I very much
fear that although you're going to be a
much more vigorous economy than Europe
you're not going to be as vigorous as
China and India okay that's a prediction
we'll see how it works out
thank you all for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you